Where do you live with Colossus owner and spoon why the mask ugly are the jokes insecure my Princess Bride
I'm a fan why Celine Dion? I'm a bigger fan by the holidays. Thought it'd be fun my pg-13
It's a family movie also money
Also Disney
Why do you think audiences will be stupid enough to swallow this not sure this level of curiosity is cute coming from middle-aged man strapped
To a bed against his will one on timing not on your fuckin life
Right before Christmas a good guy in red he's coming to theaters with his new sidekick
Fred
Why am I here so I could read you the story of Deadpool - filtered through the prism of childlike innocence
You'd save for grandmas. I love your working up and approve for teens for the first time ever Deadpool's
pg-13
The only half bomber using around here is Fred Savage once upon a Deadpool rated pg-13 in theaters
December 12, right before Christmas a good guy in red is coming to theaters with his new sidekick
Fred
Why am I here you're in a pg-13 version of Deadpool filtered
Through the prison of childlike innocence and nobody does childlike innocence like you Fred nobody
I need you almost as much as you need me. I don't need you at all me to untie you
once we're done
I
Loved your working up. I'm sorry
Don't get to a test one. So Paul no Deadpool character for Marvel movies. We are Marvel
Yeah, but you're you know, Marvel license by Fox it's like if the Beatles were produced by Nickelback, it's music, but it sucks
You were nicer as a kid rated pg-13 limited engagement in theaters, December 12th